You guys can hear it, right?
Some people were like, what are you doing?
It's the music!
It's the background music!
You hear it?
It's kind of like...
Friday the 13th.
Choo choo choo.
Ah ah ah.
The music is a little quiet.
It's so loud in my ear.
It's so loud for me.
It is not quiet.
Put it like here.
Should be better, right?
It's loud.
I don't know what they mean.
Ma'am, I joined your membership, but I have a request.
Could you use your OL skills to really sell your membership to me?
Sales pitch.
When you hear sales pitch, what do you think?
You might be intimidated.
You might think, I don't want to be sailed to...
And, you know, I'm tone-deaf, so pitch is not my forte.
I don't even like using the word forte.
Because I'm not musically inclined.
But, I would say that...
Um...
That my pitch is...
Pitch perfect.
Ahhhh!
And if you want more quality content such as that...
You should join my memberships.
The Memboo ships.
Sold.
Thank you.
Wait, now I'm low and the game is loud?
Okay, I'm gonna turn it back down then.
Oh.
I think
I have to do it manually.
Wait.
Okay.
Thank you guys for the gift and thank you.
I'll take your entire stock.
Thank you.
Thank you guys.
Wait, it lit up for like two seconds.
They turned into fake buttons.
What happened?
What even happened?
Oh, see, see, see.
It lit up.
Maybe...
I don't know.
I have no idea.
Anyway.
Hello everybody.
Welcome to That's Not My Neighbor.
Woop.
Um...
Eh...
It's a game kind of like...
Uh...
Hold on.
It's a game kind of like a Paper Please where you...
Um...
If you don't know that game, like you have people coming and you have to see what is...
What...
They are not who they say they are.
It might be that their nose is wrong or their...
Their...
They might have multiple eyeballs.
Who knows?
Anything is possible.
No.
That is not Solid Neighbor.
Exactly.
Glory to Arstotzka.
Yes, but today we are...
I don't know where we are actually.
Wait!
It's February 1955.
We're in old-timey.
Dear Mint, you are getting one guide.
Love, Cheggie.
I can't tell anymore.
I can't...
Will Georgie be there?
It's hard to say.
Georgie...
Georgie is the best guy, but...
We might have imposter Georgie.
It's kind of like...
Yeah, like the...
Like some of these guys are like trying...
Trying to dress up as your neighbor, but they are not real.
They are like...
Spooky monsters and stuff.
So it's kind of fun.
So let's...
Let's just play it.
I...
I've never played this before, so...
Oh, see?
The Doppelganger?
Doppelgangers you let in don't kill you immediately, but at the end of the run.
Okay.
Get a score rank at the end of the...
I can't...
I mean, I can't choose anything else, so...
Doppelgangers is what they are called.
Okay.
Possibility to find and complete the Chester's Quiz.
I have no idea what that is.
I've never played this before.
Oh.
But we are going to check it out.
Eww.
The following short film is a production of DDD with Educational Phi.
Okay.
Finds.
Finds?
Hello, if you're watching this film, it's because you're the new doorman in your building.
Your job is to determine whether the person who wants to enter the building is a doppelganger.
As everyone knows, doppelgangers have the ability to transform into another person and impersonate them.
But some are not too good at it and could generate imperfections.
You have to pay close attention to the appearance of your neighbors.
I have to be really judgmental.
Got it.
Also, remember to fill out the checklist for each neighbor.
Okay.
You can't miss any detail because it could mean death for you and your neighbors.
Ah!
This is the structure of your office.
Now we are going to explain how it works.
This is so cute.
Here is the security window.
Don't forget to observe very well each individual who approaches.
Okay.
My big eyes.
On the right, you have the folders with all the data of each neighbor according to the respective floor.
To fill out the checklist, take each one of the lists in front of you.
What?
Receive documents from this hatch.
Okay.
I should probably be paying attention, right?
Be, be, be.
If you determine that the individual isn't a doppelganger, then allow them into the building with these buttons.
The apostrophe.
Otherwise, if you determine that it is in fact a doppelganger, press the emergency button and call 3312.
Okay.
To communicate with the neighbor.
DDD.
Or any apartment in your building, use the telephone in front of you.
I've never seen a telephone before.
Oh, hot dog.
Yippee.
Yee-haw.
We're in the future.
Your job is really important, so make sure you do it right.
What was the number?
Uh-oh.
Finally, we congratulate the doorman of the month, Henry.
It wasn't that he did an excellent job, but he was the only doorman in the area who didn't get killed by doppelgangers.
3312, be like Henry.
But better.
Okay.
Aw, he looks so...
Like, okay.
Every time...
Oh!
Welcome and congratulations on your new job.
Oh, that's right here.
It's 3312.
As you can see in the introductory film, your job is to verify the entry of the neighbors of your building.
Each day, there will be a list.
A list of individuals who will request entry to the building.
It is possible that there are individuals who request entry and aren't on the list.
In which case, you will mark on the checklist that they are not on the list and proceed to question the individual.
Also, you must verify that the ID and the entry request are correct and have the respective DDD logo.
Don't forget to also check the expiration date on the IDs.
Remember, it's February 1955.
Yeah, yeah, I got it.
I wish you good luck.
See ya!
Okay, that was a lot of reading.
That was a lot of info at the very beginning.
Oh!
Good afternoon!
This guy looks like a real Muppet.
He looks like a Muppet on the run.
Oh my gosh.
Mucho texto.
Roman Stiltski.
483924059684.
Uh-huh.
With the DDD.
There's an idol I like that has a song called DDD.
So now I can't get it out of my head.
DDDDDDD.
I love you.
Entry request.
Roman Stiltski.
Apartment F0101.
I'm a resident of the building.
I've come from my job as a public accountant.
Accountant!
Why do you have that scar if you're just an accountant, huh?
Hmm?
Wait.
So I have to see this list.
Well, why aren't you on the...
Oh, wait.
Okay.
Checklist.
ID seems good.
Also, he's wearing a hat.
Oh, here.
Roman Stiltski.
Accountant.
Appearance.
Big nose.
Scar on right chin.
Long face.
One eyebrow.
Wears a hat!
Oh!
Where's the hat?
Wait.
One eyebrow.
ID.
Appearance.
Is it on today's...
No.
Question.
I'm not on today's list because I had to leave due to an emergency at work.
Is that a valid response or...
Entry request.
Wait.
What's the...
Is this the entry...
Oh, yes.
Caller.
I'm not on today's...
Oh.
That's sus.
Oh, call the apartment.
You're right.
Oh.
I don't know the apartment.
Ah!
Go back.
Uh.
One.
Five.
Two.
One.
Five.
Two.
One.
Yes?
Hello?
Lois Stillski speaking.
My husband is not at home.
Okay.
So, he actually did go.
Is he back?
Maybe.
I don't know.
Is it him?
It could NOT be him.
It could be an impostor maybe.
And his card was nineteen...
They wouldn't give me a fake guy on the first run, right?
Mo-si-mo-si.
He seems okay.
Okay.
I hope we don't die.
Oh.
Hello, good day.
Hello, Miss...
Raftelan Kapachinan.
What?
These old-timey names.
Oh, she's on the list.
She's on the list.
Wait.
W.
Afton?
Like a Mr. William?
William Afton?
Of Five Nights at Freddy's fame?
No way.
Also, isn't Mia Stone the name of an actress?
Okay.
Raftelian.
That sounds like reptilian.
I'm just saying.
Wait.
What floor are you on?
62.
03, 04.
I'm a resident of this building.
My apartment is on the...
Is the 04 on the third floor?
That's...
Oh, yeah.
Raftelian?
Reptilian?
Says she is a housewife.
Long face.
Big nose.
This is so judgmental.
Who are we to say that this is a big nose, right?
Hoo, hoo, hoo.
Hoo, hoo, hoo, hoo, hoo, hoo.
Hoo, hoo, hoo, hoo, hoo, hoo, hoo.
Straight hair.
She looks the same.
Right?
She wears a headband.
Yeah.
Freddy?
Hoo, hoo, hoo, hoo, hoo, hoo, hoo, hoo.
Oh, ID number.
Let's check if it's the same.
568...
554...
596...
329.
It's the same!
I'm... I think we're good.
She has a reason to go out.
She has a little thing, so I think we're good.
All right, ma'am.
Um...
Excellent.
The door, please.
You seem a little eager, Reptilian.
What if I just let you mingle out there, huh?
Blood on the dress?
I think that's a pattern.
I think that's a floral pattern.
Wait, her shirt's different?
Oh, we can't see her shirt.
I think that's a floral pattern.
I don't think that's bloody, right?
I can see the flower details on it.
Okay, let's let her in.
I don't like that sound.
It's so loud.
Okay.
I hope we don't die.
Oh!
Hello.
Lois... Stiltski?
Goddamn!
Mr. Stiltski!
Wait!
You were home!
Uh-oh.
Wait, she was...
That's not...
That's not her!
She was home?
Remember?
We already talked to her!
Goddamn!
I mean, is this...
Is...
Is this part fake, too?
Mr. Stiltski's...
He's a lucky man.
Let's do the checklist.
ID...
They might be the same.
Nice.
Hey, I know it's...
I know it's fake, but I wanna just check everything.
You know, get our ducks in an order.
See what parts are fake.
You know, 8, 9, 4, 5, 6, 9...
7, 2, 3...
6, 5, 1...
Okay.
So this is...
Oh, no, no.
Oh, wait, yes.
My teeth?
Ah!
They are for better eating, my dear!
Okay.
What does that mean?
I already answered your question.
She's getting a little spicy with me.
Eating what?
Yeah.
Eating what, ma'am?
Big lips, mole on left cheek...
Cheek!
Round face.
Short hair.
She does have a pretty round face.
It's the teeth, though.
Entry request?
Oh, yeah.
She's obviously not on the list.
So...
Oh, wait.
She does have a...
I'm not on today's list because I had to leave due to an emergency.
I'm gonna call the apartment.
What was it?
1-1-5-2.
I wanna see what they say.
1...
5...
2...
A likely story.
I like this version of Total Detective.
Hello.
Roman Stiltski speaking.
My wife and I are in the apartment right now.
Wait.
We are not expecting any information.
We're expecting a few visitors today.
What if...
What if this is the real wife?
Wouldn't that be crazy?
Um...
3-3-1-2!
Eject!
The call is coming from inside the house.
What?
Oh, I have to push the button first.
Um...
I don't know how loud this is gonna be, so I'm gonna turn it down just a little bit.
Okay, that wasn't so bad.
3-3-1-2.
Emergency!
You have contacted the D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D-D.
A group of agents has been sent to your building.
Thank you.
Please wait for the cleaning protocol to run.
Cleaning protocol?
Oh!
Cleaning protocol completed!
Thank you, sir.
You can continue your job.
Thank you very much for your service.
Cool.
Good work, Minto.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Where is your entry request?
My entry request?
Yes.
Your entry.
I think everything's fine with my...
Oh, I mean, where's your ID?
Sorry.
Uh, uh...
Lift up, lift up.
There we go.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Yes, I forgot to show my ID.
Oh.
You had it this whole time.
Hyper, thank you for the gift.
Thank you so much.
Gloria Schmidt.
I think I do remember seeing her on the list.
Yes.
0201...
1974, DDD.
Mm-hmm.
I'm a resident of this building.
I came from my job as a banker.
Wait, what floor are you again?
Two.
She's a banker?
Round face.
Mole on right cheek.
Short hair.
Round nose.
Right cheek.
Short hair.
Do we trust bankers?
Let's check her ID number.
698522...
341-150.
Yes?
I believe this one is...
Wait, what is this?
Oh.
Oh, that's handy.
Hmm.
Oh, so I can minimize...
Oh, that's so handy.
That's so handy.
I think she's good.
If we get eaten...
Oh, wait.
Let me complete the checklist.
So, is everything in order?
Yes.
Can you open the door for me?
Did you call her house?
Oh, thank you.
512...
Well, she was on the list.
But it's probably better, right?
5123.
Yeah, let's call.
Let's call.
5124, Arnold...
Whoa, the audio got weird.
Arnold, shh.
My wife is not at home.
Okay.
She's here.
Is she back?
She might be.
She could be a doppelganger?
Okay.
Minty can't slack.
I know, I'm sorry.
Oh my gosh.
Is this Emma Stone?
Good afternoon.
Good afternoon!
Mia Stone!
1978, DDD.
Who is Emma Stone?
I just know that name, but who is she?
She is an actress?
Oh, okay.
I'm a resident of this building.
My apartment is on the... is the 01 on the third floor.
Oh!
I was on the...
Oh my gosh, what a beautiful couple.
She's a teacher, long hair, small, small round nose.
I'll be the judge of that.
Now, if you're looking for a small round nose, I would use mine as an example, but...
You know what?
Whatever makes her feel good.
You know?
Has freckles, oval face, thin eyebrows.
What nose?
You have no nose!
I have a nose!
Look, you can see it.
See that?
See that nose in all its pointed glory?
Oh,
God!
I can't blow my nose!
I have no tissue!
Okay, we're fine.
No!
Okay.
We're okay.
Sorry.
Sorry to...
She's just standing here so patiently, like, I hope I don't get eaten.
789-564...
789-564 or 525-115.
525...
Oh!
I was looking at the 4-5-2... 525-115.
Okay!
Um...
She is on the list.
Excellent.
Can you open the door for me?
Not until I...
Oh, wait.
Your husband?
He might not be home either.
Oh, whoops.
But we'll try.
We'll try.
Uh... 1425.
1425...
I don't think he's gonna be home.
They're working... They're a working couple.
So neither of them are home?
Dozo?
I can't say I'm a huge fan of that beeping sound.
It's kind of...
Oh, like that.
Oh, it's so loud.
It's so loud.
Ah!
Uh...
Hello, uh...
Celine?
Uh...
Whoa!
Celine and Eleanor Nguyen live together.
Wait, they're... they're twins.
Uh...
Oh, it's Nacha!
Nacha Cheese!
Or, in this case, Nacha... Nacha Body.
Not... Nacha... Nacha You!
Hahaha...
Um... uh...
Yes?
I'll take that now.
All right, what about your appearance?
Blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Um... you don't have an entry request either.
Yeah, I mean...
I'm... I'm...
Nacha neighbor.
Yeah, yeah, Nacha neighbor.
Hahaha...
Uh... hmm...
I don't know, guys, what should we do with her?
I feel kind of bad.
Looks like she's had a hard day, you know?
Like, imagine if you, like, go and get a haircut.
You don't tell anyone.
Or, like, you know...
Some... someone, like, jumps you in the back alley and steals your eyes and your mouth.
And, like, you can't... you can't report that right away.
You can't tell them, like, hey...
Sorry, I got jumped in the alley and they stole my kidney and my eyes.
Sell on the black market.
Typical Friday.
Hahaha...
Like, and then... and then I have to call the police on you?
Like...
This is such a bad day.
She just wants to go home.
Poor Nacha.
Hahaha...
Okay.
Emergency!
Three, three, one, two.
They're coming to get you.
Little doppelganger.
You're in danger.
I'm gonna skip this, okay?
Cleaning protocol completed!
Thank you!
You can continue your job.
I wish I didn't.
That was frightening.
I hope they cover therapy.
Oh!
Hi.
Oh...
Are you guys gonna say it?
Or...
Am I gonna?
Uh...
Oh!
My appearance?
Nose?
My nose?
I was born with out a nose.
Oh my gosh.
It's normal for humans!
He was born without a nose.
It's normal.
You heard him.
You heard Mr. Robertski Peachman.
Peach fuzz.
Oh, he looks so weird.
I am a resident of the building.
I come from my job as a shoemaker.
Shoemaker 0102.
Yes, shoemaker 2668.
Also, he's not on the list.
Am I not on today's list?
I think there is an error.
I should be on the list.
Look at the list again.
I didn't.
Not there, mister.
I already answered your question.
Red flags.
Let's call 2668.
What if he picks up?
Got your nose.
Take the L, bro.
I know.
Hello, Robertski Peachman.
Wait, isn't that who that guy is supposed to be?
My brother and I are in the apartment right now.
Are you expecting visitors?
We are not expecting any visitors today.
Without the nose, he looks so much more suspicious.
Okay, buddy.
I think we're going to have to...
He did bring up a good point.
Not everybody has a nose.
Oh, three.
I forget that I have to call.
What if I just sit here for long enough?
Do they get mad?
Bust him.
Yeah, we're busting this guy.
Cleaning protocol completed.
How many more do I have to do?
How long is the day?
Milkman!
Hello.
Francis Moses.
1964.
I'm a resident of the building.
I come from my job as a milkman.
No way.
He's really a milkman.
What was your 302?
Oh, appearance.
For some reason, I read appearance.
Milkman.
Long nose.
Thin chin.
Tired eyes.
Short hair.
Can you take off your hat for me, please?
Oh, where's a hat?
Never mind.
Okay, Francis.
Let me check your...
Two, three.
Five.
Five, six, nine.
Two, three, five, five, six, nine, four, one, eight.
Nine, nine, five.
Thank you.
Wait, I can't read it.
This game is all about keeping the uggos out.
Don't be mean.
No.
Wait, is he on the list?
Oh, he is.
I think this guy is a green flag.
Perfect.
The door.
You could say, please.
Hold on.
Before I do that, I am going to...
I think it would be under sound, right?
Oh, but I want you to still hear them and stuff.
I just hate this sound.
It's so loud.
He's tired, Mint.
Yeah, me too.
Wait, is this the elusive Afton?
Dr. W.
Wait, where's the rest of your name?
Oh, Afton.
1971.
We know he's on the list.
Oh, my God.
Excuse me.
Where is your entry request?
Here is my entry.
Okay.
Just kidding.
I am a resident of the building.
I come from my job as a psych...
physicist.
Physicist.
Okay.
Yes, sir.
Physicist.
301.
Robust eyebrows.
Quite.
Wears glasses.
Short hair.
Yes.
Round nose.
Yeah.
Square head.
I hope nobody writes these for me.
I hope nobody writes these sorts of like...
Like, what would you write for me?
For my appearance?
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you for the 20.
Thank you for the 20 gifted.
You're a simp.
Thank you, Joshua.
You're an absolute jewel.
You're an absolute jewel to watch.
And I have been having so much fun watching your streams.
Keep that idol heart shining, Mint.
Have you ever heard of the band called Band Maid?
I have.
I don't know a lot about them, though, which is funny.
You'd think that they'd be like everything I love, you know?
250489.
And we know we called earlier, so we know he's out.
He's good.
Dork shape head.
Stop.
Ocelot.
McCloy.
Rudd Boys.
1958.
Oh, you're about to expire.
I'm a resident of the building.
I come from doing the shopping.
There he is.
For real.
He's retired.
Oh, he did go shopping.
Has a mustache.
Yup.
Big nose.
Goatee.
Yup.
Smokes.
Always wears a hat.
Yup.
Except in this picture.
How did you get in?
I think we're all good.
And he was on the list, right?
Oh,
let me call his house.
Can you open the door for me?
4242, give me a second.
Sir?
Oh, oops.
I grouped the 4 and the 2s together in my brain.
Liquid.
Nerd walk, lack of nose, otaku stink, sinister demeanor.
Oh, my father is not at home.
Okay, cool.
Don't worry about this.
Just a note for future reference.
I hate this.
Get in there.
Go home.
How many more people do we have?
Oh!
Ever dream this clown?
Every night, all over the world, hundreds of people see this clown in their dreams.
If this clown appears in your dreams, don't play any game with him.
If you want more information, go to nachogames.itchio slash unlikely.
It's an ad!
Hey!
Skip ad, skip ad.
Oh, my gosh.
I can't believe we got an ad in our game.
Hello!
Margaret Bubbles.
Yes, Margaret Bubbles.
Your eyes are looking a little lazy.
It's okay.
It's probably your charm point.
0203.
She's a seamstress.
Curly hair.
Oh, my God, it is!
Deviated left eye!
It is actually a charm point.
Round nose.
Yeah.
Big smile.
Okay.
I'm not dreaming of the clown.
I'm dreaming of Bubbles.
Jumbo.
I said jumbles.
Is Bubbles your dream lady?
I'm dreaming of Margaret Bubbles.
Hmm.
What?
Oh, let me check her ID.
First.
103-268-014-590.
I think she's good.
Enjoy the rest of your life.
I'm not brave enough to marry this woman.
She would make a man out of you.
Hello.
You're one of the sisters.
You're Celine's sister.
1980.
Wait, are you on the list?
Celine's sister.
I'm a resident of this building.
My apartment is on the fourth...
Is the 04 on the first floor?
She's...
Okay.
The mole is on the correct side.
She's got the earrings.
Okay.
Mole on right cheek.
Small pointed nose.
Yes.
Slim.
Okay.
Long neck.
She has a twin.
That's not an appearance.
That doesn't mean anything.
Let's try...
6...
9...
What was the other sister's name?
Elise or...
Illinois...
Illinois's...
sister.
My sister is not at home.
Okay.
Oh.
Fine.
785-613.
269-514.
Sorry.
We're good.
Have a nice life.
What am I...
I just...
I locked the door in front of her.
Mm-hmm.
Oh.
Good afternoon.
Mr. Albertzki Peachman.
What is up with the peaches?
Why?
What?
Do they have a lot of money or something?
No.
Their name...
They are peaches!
They sound delicious!
That's why all the monsters want to impersonate and eat them.
Peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, peaches, I love you!
We might want to ask him about the eye thing.
Come from my job as a shoemaker.
Was he on the list?
No...
My appearance?
Yeah, I just want to know.
I don't see anything strange with my appearance.
I can see it well with my one eye.
Welcome to membership, thank you!
Minto droopy eyes, no nose, tiny cute dead.
Tiny cute dead?
Always wears a mid dress.
Until the day I don't.
That would be shocking.
I already answered your question.
I want to see if he gets like a little upset, you know?
Like if he's just like, hey!
Maybe not.
I think it's time we um, danger.
Thanks for the vibe gift!
Thank you!
Three, three, one, two!
Don't you roll your eye at Mint.
Yeah, don't roll your eye at me mister.
Nice.
I'm gonna continue my job.
When will this day end?
Do you guys hear the...
I want to know if it's part of the game or if you guys hear like the buzzing also.
I can't tell if it's my headphones or not.
Good afternoon!
Um, where is your entry request?
Thank you.
Oh, you do hear the buzz?
Okay.
I think it's the game then.
I was worried it was my headphones.
You are not on the list!
Uh...
Am I not on today's list?
Thanks for the gift.
I think there is an error.
I should be on the list.
Look at the list again.
I don't see you on the list.
What's your name?
Arnold Schmidt.
I came... I come from my job as a writer.
You have the wrong mustache!
What's wrong with my appearance?
Look carefully at the photos of my papers and compare them well with me.
This guy!
You are not slick!
I love though that the... actually...
This doppelganger actually went to like the department and was just like, hey!
I'm here to renew my ID!
It was like, I've got to get a new picture!
New year, new me, new mustache!
778-566 219-322 Let's call home 5123.
People can change mustaches.
Not here!
Not in this 1955!
That is ridiculous!
That is absolutely absurd!
Gloria Schmidt speaking, yes.
Where's your husband?
They're in the apartment right now!
Are you expecting a second husband?
Are you sure you don't want...
What's better than one husband?
Two!
What if this is like...
This is like her...
Her like side husband.
It looks like the exact same.
She has a very specific type.
Just this guy has a silly mustache instead.
Goodbye!
Doppelganger?
Side husband.
Yeah.
Gosh, you guys are busy today!
Do we usually get this many...
This many...
Doppelgangers?
No wonder I'm needed.
Wow!
Thank you so much for that 20!
Thank you!
Hello, Steven.
My face?
Yeah.
A paper?
I don't know what you're saying.
I'm pretty sure we called this guy earlier.
I'm pretty sure he...
Yeah, we had to call him to see about his dad.
Big nose...
Wears sunglasses...
Not the smiley face emoji.
I thought you guys were like warning me about spoilers.
Short hair...
Small hair...
What's wrong with the size of his head?
His head is normal!
What do you mean?
Ghost of Mint!
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
You're a ghost of a ghost?
That's crazy.
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
Thank you.
What's wrong with the size of his head?
4'2".
Yes, remember because I messed this up.
Steven speaking.
My father and I are in the apartment right now!
Are you not expecting a second self?
Hmm...
I'm gonna give you one last shot mister.
I wanna see actually... Hold on.
What if I do this?
I wanna try this.
So is everything in order?
Can you open the door for me?
Oh.
Dang.
I thought like...
Peek a peek a peek a peek.
I thought something funny would happen, you know?
Alright.
Gosh.
These guys just need to remain on site too.
Let him in!
We're playing the game proper now.
We'll have some fun like shenanigans stuff later.
Oh.
Oops.
Skip.
Skip cleaning protocol.
Can't stop yawning!
Thank you sir.
Thank you.
How much longer?
Oh!
100% accuracy.
Six doppels.
Neighbors killed zero.
Zero?
Rank S.
Oh!
Easy!
Nice detail.
Play again.
Skip.
Goodbye.
Hello.
Wow.
Peach Man!
Good afternoon, Peach Man.
Give me your ID.
Yes.
You forgot to show your ID.
Can't believe that Cyclops was a doppel.
They're really tricky, aren't they?
They really try to get you.
Let's see.
Albertsky Peach Man.
Hmm.
I'm arisen at this building.
I come home from my job as a shoemaker.
You're both shoemakers?
Oh.
You both are actually shoemakers.
Let's see.
Your hair seems to be in order.
Your nose.
Yeah.
Prominent chin.
Very much so.
You have the big chin.
Your brother has the no chin.
What?
They don't write that in the appearance though?
No chin?
I guess they have a little bit of...
A little bit of self...
A little bit of respect for these...
For these...
For these residents, huh?
He looks too convincing.
Let's check his numbers.
146512?
146512... 986...
96354...
Are you on the list?
He is!
Wow.
There's not so many people on the list today.
Yes.
Peter Griffin looking guy.
Don't be rude.
Good afternoon, Arnold Schmidt.
That's you.
Come from my job as a writer?
Wait.
Oh!
All the apartments are different now too.
201...
Or I'm just going crazy.
He is a writer!
Oh!
He is a writer.
778...
566...
219...
322...
Yep.
Big eyebrows.
Yeah.
Prominent mustache.
Wears a hat.
Round face.
Yeah.
Short hair.
Mustache looks different.
No.
It's the same.
And he is on the list.
Oh!
You know what?
I forgot to call the previous person.
Didn't I?
Whoopsie.
5123.
Let's try again.
Let's try this.
We could have died first try.
First person.
Hmm.
I guess we'll see at the end of the day.
Gloria Schmidt speaking.
My husband is not at home.
Okay.
Good.
What if I try calling them right now?
You know?
What was the floor?
Where did that guy live?
Oh here.
2668.
Let's just...
Let's try.
2668.
Yeah.
Let's try calling now.
Oh wait.
Oh they might be...
If they don't pick up, maybe they're dead.
Oh my gosh!
He's alive!
My brother and I are in the apartment right now.
And there's an intruder!
Oh my god!
We're dead!
Save us!
I think we're good.
Okay.
We just have to burn...
It's like when you see a spider in your room.
You just have to...
42?
You just have to burn the whole place down?
42.
43.
Oh!
42, 42, 42.
Is this 42 ones?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12.
12 times 3.
2, 4, 6, 36, 37, 38, 39, 40, 41, 42!
Who would have thought?
I think he means well.
He's quite obviously just trying to teach the youngins how to count.
I've never seen Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy so...
He's a man who knows what he wants.
42!
Not 41.
Not 43.
42!
Anyway...
Oh.
I just realized that the date actually didn't change which is kind of disappointing.
Thank you!
What are the trophies that I keep getting?
Are they under here?
Or maybe on the menu.
When I was a part of hockey team, my number was 42.
No way!
Hi or whatever.
Hi.
Anastacia.
1985.
I live here.
Whatever.
I come from school.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
She's got her little Seifuku.
So cute.
She's not on the list though.
Ma'am, you are not on the list.
I'm not on today's list because I had to leave due to an emergency.
Or whatever.
Ever.
What one was she?
Oh, here.
Tired eyes.
Yeah.
Two ponytails.
Small nose.
Round face.
She checks out.
132 698 53 44 Yeah.
We're gonna call Chef.
Wait.
What if she's not there though?
Okay.
1346 Welcome to Mamusha.
Thank you.
Hello.
What?
My mother is...
Whatever.
Sneaky.
What if I say, like, ID?
My ID?
Are you gonna get mad at me?
Little doppelganger?
I don't see anything wrong with my ID.
Whatever.
Oh my gosh.
She's even got her mannerisms down.
What's wrong with my appearance?
Everything is in order with my appearance.
Whatever.
She's even got her mannerisms down.
My entry request?
Everything is fine with my entry request.
Is that a zipper on her back?
This right here?
Let's check her picture.
No.
She has it in the original too.
I think it might be...
Maybe part of the backpack.
Like the handle bar of the backpack.
You know?
Okay.
Anyway.
Three, three, one, two...
What's stopping these doppelgangers from just, like, climbing the window?
You know?
Whatever.
That was tricky.
If we hadn't called...
Imagine, like, the first one!
The first one was completely fine.
If we hadn't called...
Well, I guess...
Well, he was on the list, actually, now that I think about it.
Oh my gosh!
Emma Stone!
Mia Stone!
Came back from my job as a teacher.
Her hips don't lie either.
Wow.
You are not on the list.
Am I not on today's list?
It must be a mistake.
I should be on the list.
No, you're not.
You're not!
Wait.
Who do you live with?
301?
Oh yes!
Of course!
How could I forget?
W.
Afton.
She looks the exact same.
From what I can tell.
Ahem.
Hmm...
1425.
The real giveaway for the last doppel was actually her entry request was missing the DDD logo.
Wait.
Who just picked...
Oh!
Oh, wait!
Was that Afton?
Sorry, I missed the name.
I was reading the comment.
Did he say Mia?
That was Afton?
Oh, okay.
Then...
I guess she...
Okay, let's check the number.
789...
I need to be better about the DDD logos then.
Because I didn't even notice at all.
Good eye.
789-564...
525-115.
Lady, make sure you properly get your stuff in order next time for going out.
Yes.
You need to properly get your stuff in order.
It wasn't a mistake.
You didn't fill out the proper paperwork.
But I'm gonna let you in.
Hmm.
Hello, good day.
Where's your ID?
Sorry, here's my ID.
Yeah, I was about to literally call the police on you.
I was about to get your butt annihilated.
They were going to come and they were going to literally destroy you.
Reptilian.
Hmm.
But you know...
I went out to visit my parents.
I mean, she is on the list.
Long face, big nose...
Straight hair, wears a headband.
568-554...
596...
329...
Let me call your home.
I must talk to ALF right away.
4258...
4... 2...
5... 8...
That guy looks like he's Bruce Wayne's butler.
My goodness.
Hmm.
ALF speaking.
My wife is not at home.
Okay.
Yes.
Maybe.
It could be some sinister beast waiting for you to trust it so that it can pounce and suck all your blood from your body.
I forgot to show my entry request.
How long have you been living here, Robertski?
You forget to show your entry request every time.
I'm sick of this.
I'm just gonna... Oh!
1-1-4-3.
But also, he's not on the list.
But, yeah, it is missing the logo, it's missing the logo.
16 Nigeria.
I already answered your question.
1-1...
1-1... Wait, where...
1-1-4-6-5-2.
1-1-4-6-5-2 2-8-9-7-3-0 3-8-9-7-3-0?
The appearance looks fine, but we must call your brother.
Or... I mean, they kind of look like they'd be brothers more than lovers, right?
I think?
But isn't there a thing that some people like to date people they look like or something?
I don't know.
They're brothers.
Robertski Peachman speaking.
My brother and I are in the apartment!
We are not expecting any visitors today.
My entry request?
I think everything's fine with my entry request.
That's something a doppelganger would say.
I'm not on today's list because I had to leave due to an emergency at work.
Likely story...
3, 3, 1, 2...
I think this game is relaxing so much it's making me so tired.
Oops, sorry if you just heard me kick my mic.
I'd rather I need it while I was adjusting.
Bust down.
Bust him!
So sleepy today.
Next please.
Wait.
Didn't we see you earlier or...
Didn't we see you earlier?
1, 4, 2, 5.
We did?
We just let her in?
Pick up.
Clearly, that means there's two wives.
Clearly, that means if I let both of them in, he'll be so hap- What's the difference in appearance?
Did I get the appearance on the other lady wrong?
Or is this the one that's the fake?
Uh oh...
This all looks good, though!
This all looks good!
Check the freckles...
They look the same...
Uh oh...
Is the job right?
Alright.
Yeah.
I checked the numbers.
Let's check up again.
789-564-525-115.
Yeah.
But I checked it last time too.
Wait, but he would have been eaten though, right?
Her birthday.
This isn't the birthday.
This is the expiration date.
Sorry, the chat is kind of blocking it.
But it's currently February 1955.
I just checked the expiration.
Make sure it's not.
Call again.
1-4-2-5.
Oh my gosh, am I going to have to kill an innocent person?
Maybe.
Yeah, you're still alive?
They're in the apartment.
How?
I just want to know.
Sss.
How would I know?
That this is the impostor?
They don't kill immediately?
Look at the logos.
I am.
I actually don't remember what the logo is supposed to look like.
They don't give a reference.
So I just have to believe that this is the correct thing.
I think this is the real one.
I think so too.
Try asking questions again.
My ID?
I don't see anything wrong with my ID.
What's wrong with my appearance?
You...
The eyeshadow is not flattering on you.
Put them both in.
Problem solved.
Either way, even if I call the DDD on this lady, she's going to die.
So, yeah.
Okay.
You're welcome, Mr. Afton.
Now you have two wives.
Lucky you.
Good afternoon.
Why are you not on the list?
Now they both die.
If I had called the DDD on the lady standing here, she would have died anyway.
So now...
You know...
They're all just...
It's just how the circle of life works.
Gloria Schmidt.
She's not on the list.
But she is a banker.
1974.
Round face.
Mole on right cheek.
The nose!
The nose is wrong.
What's wrong with my appearance?
Look carefully at my photos of my papers and compare them well with me.
Oh.
Ma'am.
I assure you, I am.
I assure you, Gloria Schmidt of the bank.
I am doing that.
But I am going to call just in case.
5...
1...
2...
3...
I think there was a grammar error when you asked about her appearance.
I'm inclined to believe maybe that the game dev is maybe not...
maybe English second language or something because there's been a lot of grammar errors.
So I'm not kind of like putting that as a...
as a...
thing.
Pop the button.
Wee woo!
Oh.
Skip, skip, skip.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Call Afton back.
You're right.
We should...
1-4-2-5...
Oh, I can't call yet.
Oh!
Heterochromia.
Good afternoon.
One second.
I have to make sure someone else is dead.
He's probably going to be like, look!
Dorman, I have two wives!
I'm the luckiest man in this world!
Wait, what is he going to say?
My fianc and I are in the apartment right now.
We're not expecting any visitors today.
Interesting.
Wait, does she usually have...
It's Nacha.
0-2-0-4...
Right eye blue!
Left eye green!
Wait, actually!
Oh!
She does actually have heterochromia.
Curly hair.
Yeah.
Freckles.
Round face.
She looks good to me.
But she's not on the list.
You're right or hers?
It has to be her right, right?
No, I'm pretty sure it's her right.
Because everything else has said, like, mole on right cheek.
And it's been correct.
It's her right.
She's a chef.
Resident of the building.
I come from my job as a chef.
You can also kind of see it in the picture, too.
See, like, this looks darker and this one looks lighter.
Her nose is gone.
6-5-5-4-1-3.
I'm so sorry that I'm yawning so much.
I don't know why.
1-3-4-6.
I don't know how we got the first Mia wrong!
I don't know!
Nacha means butt cheek in Spanish.
That's so mean!
My mother is not at home.
Okay.
How did we mess up?
I still think second Mia was...
Was wrong?
I think you got the first Mia right.
Really?
You think so?
You think maybe just because she was...
Even though she was perfect...
She...
I don't know.
Oh, whoops, sorry.
Uh...
What is underneath there?
What was that?
Um...
Some doppelgangers can be perfect.
They can?
Oh.
Well...
I think he's really appreciative.
Wait.
Was it second floor?
There we go.
She looks right to me.
Even though you're not on today's list.
Can you...
Can you tell me again why?
I think there's an error.
I should be on the list.
Oh, well.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Let her in.
I almost just murdered an innocent lady.
Oh, no.
Oh, well.
Oh.
Good afternoon.
Angus.
Prime beef.
Five, six, five...
Wait.
Where are you at?
Oh, one, oh, three.
Five, six, five, zero, zero, three.
Six, nine, eight, eight, four, five.
Yes.
Business man.
Long neck.
Where are you?
There's a hat.
Mm-hmm.
Has a mustache.
Small eyes.
68.
D, D, D.
Resident of the building.
I come from my job as a businessman.
And you are on the list.
I'm gonna call you...
Wait.
No one else would pick up.
You're the only one home.
Wait.
What if I pick up and...
Or what if I call and he's there?
Okay.
45513.
Brontosaurus.
Oh my god, his teeth are like a whale's.
They look like, you know how whales have like, oh, yeah, he's not there.
You know how whales have like those really, they look like really packed together hay barrels.
Ooh.
Hello, peach man.
What?
Give me your ID, please.
Yeah, you did.
You forgot to show your ID.
Now I'm even more suspicious of you.
Wasn't he here already?
He was?
Wait, where are you at?
0102.
2668?
We're not gonna make the same mistake again.
Robert Ski Peach Man?
You and your brother?
My brother and I are in the apartment right now!
We are not expecting any visitors today.
And this one has no logo.
I'm not on today's list because I had to leave due to an emergency at work.
Likely story, doppelganger.
Get... exterminated.
What do they do with the doppelgangers?
Why do we have a doppelganger problem anyway?
What kind of...
What... what kind of... what is going on here?
Skinwalker Ranch.
Wow.
Oh!
Good afternoon!
He looks like...
That one actor.
Isaac.
He looks like... John Stamos?
Is that his name?
Aliens.
Did you guys know that there is an alien... ancient aliens...
Like the TV show that there's a game?
You can get it on Steam.
I've thought about playing it.
He's a reporter.
Big eyebrows.
Big smile.
Prominent chin.
Big nose.
Why are you so rude to him?
Why are you so...
Stream it?
I've thought about it.
But it's one of those types of games where it's like...
Okay, build this thing.
It's going to take...
It's going to take 12 hours to build.
4, 5, 6, 9, 8, 5, 5, 1, 2, 3, 6, 9.
Resident of the building.
My apartment is on the second...
Second, second floor.
That's right.
Let's call just in case.
7, 3, 3, 2.
12 hours.
12 hours waiting, Stream.
Yeah.
I'll do like...
We'll just have it on in the background and we can be like, okay.
No ID?
No he has an ID.
He seems good I think.
It seems...
Like at the end of streams, we'll be like, where are aliens?
No date.
You're right!
Oh my gosh, wait.
Things are not in order?
Things?
Let me checklist.
Uh oh.
Well let me click the checklist again.
Is it because I already gave the okay?
You can still call?
Sorry if you were innocent.
Sorry.
Sorry if you were innocent, man.
But I don't think you were.
I think you had a fraudulent ID.
I think you're a doppelganger.
You're about to get exterminated.
They're about to come in and literally set you on fire.
He was sus.
Uh oh.
Jabba's a reporter.
No!
What?
There it is!
4, 5, 6.
You guys saved me before too.
I was so close.
9, 8, 5, 5, 1, 2, 3, 6, 9.
I was two seconds away from letting him in, you guys.
I was two seconds away.
The building I've come from my job is a reporter.
Good job, team.
Can you imagine this guy walking up to his apartment and seeing a doppelganger of himself being dragged out?
I think I would tip the door, man.
I'd be like, good job!
Good job, man.
Siege, thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you!
That would ruin my life.
No, I'd be like, good job, doorman.
You're doing a good job.
Wait, so yeah, he's not there.
Because we already called before.
Yeah.
Good job, team.
Oh, it's James.
Steven.
Where do you live?
303.
Oh, gosh.
Big nose.
Yup.
Yup, wear sunglasses.
Short hair.
Small hair.
Ori, thank you for the 10 gifted.
Thank you!
565845.
455965.
Yep.
Steven Red Boys.
And I know he's on the list.
Let's call up his place of residence.
4242.
Hey,
now.
I have a huge head.
You say that, Steve.
You say that.
My son is not at home.
Is he back?
I think so.
I don't know anymore after Mia.
I have no idea anymore.
I'm gonna check his appearance one last time.
Yeah.
Okay.
42?
Nose?
What do you mean, nose?
His nose is fine.
Oopsie.
I was not better than that guy at the beginning.
Six doppelgangers.
Ah.
Wait.
What do you mean neighbors killed zero?
Mia, fake documents.
Ah.
Where's Mia?
Which one, though?
Which one?
Now aim for an F.
Actually, I do want to go to the menu.
Because, um...
Record?
Is that...
Oh, here we go.
Achievements?
Oh, wow.
You can get...
Wow.
B, C, D, E, F.
Achievements.
Oh, look at that.
Meet the clown.
Discover the secret of the universe.
Finish one playthrough alive.
Be murdered.
Get S rank on one playthrough.
Better than Henry!
Kill one neighbor.
Wait, how do I kill a neighbor?
Since you told me you read my letter, I can't stop wondering what you thought about it.
I hope I wasn't too embarrassing.
No!
It was so nice!
Thank you.
Yeah, it was so nice.
Oh!
Call DDD on someone innocent.
Got it.
Capture a hundred doppelgangers.
Complete any folder?
That's not possible.
Complete Chester's quiz.
Who's Chester?
Survive 40 playthroughs.
Get F rank on one playthrough.
Unlock all achievements.
Meet the peach doppelganger.
Catch a doppelganger red-handed.
What?
Complete 100 playthroughs.
What's the peach?
Wait, did we not...
Peaches peaches.
Do we not meet the peach doppelganger?
Do we get the doppelganger of the peach bros?
Hmmm...
Peaches peaches peaches.
Peaches peaches peaches decides!
I love you!
Ad greaterfrage!
Oh oh.
It sure would be something to 100% this game.
I know, right?
I think this one, Steal Memory, that is not my... that is not...
That is rough for me.
Like, capture a hop... hopple... capture 100 doppelgangers is doable.
You just have to play the game a lot.
I mean, we are already at 12, so...
And... 40 playthroughs.
I think you can get both of these, you know?
Let's try again.
Oh, let's try again.
At least get like the peach one.
And whatever the quiz is, I do... I'm curious about that.
The ones that are like the special doppelgangers, I'm most curious about.
And then, I guess they'll be adding more modes in the future.
That'll be fun.
Unless you unlock them when you get more achievements.
That'll be fun, though.
Ian!
Vivian!
Welcome to Bamboo Ship.
Thank you, bro!
Thank you!
A hopple dundridgangers.
Yeah.
Oh, we can skip this.
Hello!
Skip!
See ya!
Are we doing... this time?
Let's get an F.
Hello.
We have to... to get an F, since it was the lowest and there were so many in between, we probably have to get every single one incorrect.
Whoa!
Wee!
Full day!
Wow!
Which one is you?
Selene.
Every night in my dreams, I see you.
I feel you.
Selene has it on the right side.
Pointed nose.
Yeah.
Slim.
Maybe.
I don't know.
I guess.
Long neck.
Short.
Twin.
So, if this is correct, that means we call the cops on her.
Both have logos.
So, seven, eight, five.
Six, one, three.
Two, six, nine.
Five, one, four.
I think we need to call the cops on Selene Dion.
Oh, call the house.
Yes.
Let's call the house.
Six, nine, nine, six.
Genocide run.
Yup.
So, this time we are going for all inaccurate.
No one's home.
Get her out of here.
You will not survive here.
You will not ever see your family again.
Thank you.
Let's hope we get some obvious doppelgangers in here.
I like Roman.
Roman.
We haven't seen you in a while.
I hope you're a doppelganger so I don't have to kill you.
One, one.
Yeah, you got that.
Lucky, lucky.
You're a lucky man.
You know that?
You're a lucky, lucky man.
Mr. Roman Stilnski.
Big nose.
Yeah.
Scar on right chin.
Long face.
Yeah.
One eyebrow.
Where's a hat?
You can't be correct.
He has an expiration date.
483-924-059-684.
No!
Oh wait, is he on a list?
Let's call his house.
1-1-5-2.
Let's check.
It's a villager.
Huh.
Louis Stilnski speaking.
No.
I'm not on today's list because I had to leave due to an emergency at work.
You're an accountant.
What kind of an emergency would there be?
Wee!
Hmm.
07.
Mr. Roman.
The numbers were wrong?
No they weren't.
They were?
483-924-059-684.
They're all right.
Oh!
Oh, you mean the numbers in the account...
You mean there was an accounting error.
Not an error from me.
Oh, man.
07.
Have your doppelganger come back.
Emergency accounting.
Hey, Su!
I've contacted the day-day-day.
See you later.
There was an emergency he didn't account for.
Good afternoon, Gloria.
Gloria.
Round face.
Mole on the right cheek.
Short hair.
Round nose.
You're looking perfect today, Gloria.
I might have to call the cops on you.
Job is a banker.
I work at the bank.
Umm...
Can their names be written wrong and stuff?
I wonder how small the details go into, you know?
He didn't really...
...excel today.
Ohhhh...
He didn't calculate how poor I am.
Or... this would be... for him!
Boo!
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
I knew you'd love it!
Boo!
Yes!
Thank you.
I knew you guys would love it.
6-9-8-5-2-2 3-4-1 1-5-0 I have to make an O emote to go with the B.
I do, I do, I do.
5-1-2-3
Let's see...
Hello, Arnold Schmidt speaking.
My wife is not at home.
Is she back?
Oh, she's back, alright.
Back...
She's...
Back to jail!
She's back to...
Back to being a baby!
In...
In the tummy!
It's like she was never born!
Yet...
Or ever again.
Hello.
Can I have your ID, please?
Thank you.
Mr. Robertski.
Are you on the list?
You are.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
The game is glitching.
It's glitching again.
It won't let me click on his file.
Shoemaker, we know that.
I don't know what his phone number is.
Hold on.
I think it's 2-6-6-8.
Oh, whoops.
Gotta trust you.
2-6-6-8.
Oh!
You were right!
Wait, Robertski.
My brother is not at home.
Yeah, cause he's Robertski and he's Albertski.
Peachman, Peachman.
Yes, thank you.
Okay.
So we knew he was out.
We have the DDD.
We got the expiration date.
It's good.
Uh...
His appearance looks fine to me.
I don't...
I can't...
I think I remember what he looks like.
We know he's a baby.
He's a shoemaker.
Get out of here, Peachman.
Can I undo this once I...
Oh, I can.
Okay, that's kinda nice.
Just kidding.
This guy is just like, No, please don't kill me!
No!
No, God!
Oh, God, please!
I'm just kidding, Robertski.
I'm not kidding.
Death to you!
Death to you, Peachman!
And he's behind there.
He's like, No, please!
Oh, God!
Sperrys, please!
Oh, Sperry!
I'm just kidding.
I'm just...
Oh, my gosh.
It's just a prank, bro!
It's just a pr...
Oh, no.
Never mind.
Off with his head!
Do you get anything for making more ghosts?
Like commission?
Unfortunately, no.
Oh, my God.
Actually, the afterlife is kind of crowded.
I don't think they want more ghosts.
All righty.
Next person, please.
Hello.
I think we killed your sister earlier.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, we can't click the first floor anymore at all?
Oh, the game is so bugged.
Nice.
Does anyone know her... her phone number?
She might actually be a doppelganger.
I don't know.
I can't tell.
I don't remember which side the mall is supposed to be on.
No job.
She's a model.
I remember that.
ViviCore, thanks for the gift.
It's 3312.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys, for helping.
She's on the list.
You guys tricked me.
Hi!
Oh, her picture would be on the list.
You're so right.
Oh, wait.
It looks just like...
I don't like her.
Yeah, Illinois.
6996!
How could I forget?
Thanks, 6J and Kyoma.
Thank you.
They're not there?
Wait.
Oh, wait.
No.
Because I killed the sister before.
It would make sense that...
Nobody's home.
Right?
And her little ahoge is going in the right direction.
Did he just make these characters and flip them?
I put 69, 69!
Nine!
Six!
Oh, my god.
Oh, I need to sleep properly tonight for real.
I'm gonna have trouble tomorrow.
Okay, it's the same reaction though.
I think I'm just gonna have to kill her.
Let the sisters be together.
Exactly, exactly.
Thank you!
Oh, he's still talking.
I need some more tea.
Bye bye.
See you later.
Next person, please!
Good afternoon.
Where is your entry request?
I'm already sussy of you.
Mia Stone.
I think she is on the list.
Yeah.
301.
Looks the same.
Let's count the freckles.
Yep.
Thin eyebrows.
Oval face.
She's a teacher.
Indeed she is.
Emma Stone.
Let's call 1425.
1425.
You know what annoys me even more about those who got me with the 3312 being the twins' number?
The fact that I so sincerely thanked you guys for for for helping me.
I was just like, oh my gosh, thank you guys.
Because the game is glitching for me, I can't check myself.
You guys are so awesome for helping me out.
I so sincerely thanked you being like my you know wisps are so great.
They're so helpful and kind.
You know Gliss, I don't want to see that.
I don't want to see that from you.
One guide hard?
It was two people!
It was two of them.
I got two guides.
Let's see.
Appearance seems fine.
ID?
789564 789564 525115 525115 Mia Stone.
I hope you said some lovely things to your friends.
Hello, I'm your husband, tonight.
I mean last night, I mean this morning.
What is wrong with me?
Anyway, okay.
You know what?
Let's just send her away.
Let's just get her out of here.
Low on brain juice.
Oh my gosh.
Do your ears hang low?
Do they wobble to and fro?
Can you tie them in a knot?
Can you tie them in a bow?
Can you throw them over...
Can you hand this to me, Francis?
What happened to your ears?
My ears?
I spread them out to here better.
Makes sense to me.
Have a nice day, Francis.
Can you throw them over your shoulder?
Like a something, some...
Hello.
Uh-oh.
Oh, we can tie it!
We can click it again!
Nice!
Celine is right... or left side.
She escaped.
Oh no, she's a perfect...
The third lost child.
The mole on entry is wrong?
What do you mean?
No, it's correct.
She's Celine.
Her name is spelled wrong.
No, it's not.
It's correct.
How am I supposed to know which one was the right...
Okay.
I'm going to make an educated guess here.
What?
It's missing an S.
Oh, her last name!
Sivert... Sivert... Oh!
My ID?
I don't see anything wrong with my ID.
Well, okay.
This was going to be my educated guess anyway.
This was going to be my educated guess that she was the doppelganger anyway.
Because...
Say we let the first two in because they were correct.
They were correct.
Even if she was so perfect...
Well...
It would have had to been the doppelganger.
You know?
Anyway...
Bye-bye!
Hmm...
I don't...
Oh, she is on the list!
That's why she went outside.
Because she was on the list.
Have a nice day!
Oh, no!
She is French!
Good afternoon.
Good afternoon, Angus.
Well, okay.
You know what?
I did ask earlier, I think, if the names could be misspelled.
And that answers my question, doesn't it?
The person before.
Average mint enjoyer.
What do you mean by that?
103.
Long neck.
Wears a hat.
Has a mustache and small eyes.
He is a businessman.
565...
003...
6...
9...
8...
4...
5...
Looks good to me!
Except...
Oh, sir.
Oh, no, sir.
You are quite suspicious.
If I do say so myself.
But, I will call your home.
And see.
5513.
Mm-hmm.
Oh, I thought someone picked up for a second!
I wouldn't trust anyone with that smile.
Look, you can't judge a book by its cover, okay?
This guy, he's just...
He's just Angus Kipriani.
Wait, what floor was it?
Oh, first floor.
Angus Kipriani.
You are under arrest for tax evasion!
So far, I think we're doing pretty well.
I think we're doing well, you guys.
I think we're gonna get this F for sure.
I think we're gonna get it for sure.
You can continue your job.
Thank you!
Here, boss.
I'm taking responsibility for accidentally gaslighting you with the accountant's numbers-related emergency.
No!
I hope you can get some well-deserved rest after this stream is over and have a great weekend.
You too!
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
We got Francis back.
He's a milkman.
Thank you.
He's on the list.
Heretic!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Alright, let's check your... your... numbers.
2355.
6941.
8995!
His expiration date is good!
He's a DDD.
DDD!
I just let you in earlier, actually, Francis.
So, um... what are you doing back here?
Hmm?
I just let you in.
Let's make sure, like, the nose and stuff, though, because some of these tinier details could probably get us tripped up.
We think that they're fine, but they're actually not.
I think with this one, we're good.
I am 100% not baked.
I saw this Zipper chat.
Ah!
Oh!
Cleaning protocol completed.
Continue your job.
Yes, sir.
Thank you, sir.
See you later.
Sir...
Oh my gosh!
You're back!
Yes!
You!
Of course!
The mom.
Nacha!
How are you doing today, Nacha?
I'm good.
Oh.
I mean...
Yeah?
Nacha, I mean...
Usually, people just say, I'm fine.
No need to trauma dump on me or anything.
I get it.
Okay.
All right.
Let's just let her in.
Let her have a... you know, get some rest, Nacha!
Those...
Those will heal eventually.
Don't worry.
Okay.
Don't worry, Nacha.
Let's see.
Enough,  twitter.
Reptilian.
Capuccino.
I'm arisen in this building, I went out to visit my parents.
Where do you live?
304.
She's a housewife.
Long-face.
Big nose.
Straight hair.
Wears a headband.
Yeah, looks...
Looks pretty right to me.
Looks pretty good.
She's on the list.
Didn't this lady show up earlier?
Did she?
I can't remember.
The games are bleeding into each other.
I'm interested in what would happen if you call since you let her other in.
Let's try it.
Who is it?
One, three, four, six.
Yeah, see?
We just let her in.
Oh, she wasn't on the list.
For some reason I was confusing her with Nacha.
So I was like, wait, but you were on the list for real actually.
Hey Mintz, it's my friend Chris's birthday.
It would make him very happy if you could sing him happy birthday.
I can!
Also Simba, thank you for that birthday gift.
Thank you so much!
Happy birthday.
Hold on.
Okay, one more time.
One more time.
Happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Chris.
Happy
birthday.
This lady looks good, doesn't she?
Lots of...
Lots of humans today, eh?
Ugh, it's exhausting.
Really giving the DDD a run for their money.
Wait.
Hey Mintz, it's my friend Chris's birthday.
Huh?
It would make him very happy if you could sing him happy birthday.
What?
It's definitely not the same Chris.
Huh?
Can't you use the same one though?
What?
Yeah, is it a doppelganger Chris?
Does your Chris have a mole on his left side or his right side?
Hello Nacha!
Actually, I feel like we can automatically let this lady in.
Because we already called before and we saw that Nacha was at home.
You know?
Right eye blue.
Left eye green.
No DDD.
Oh, you're right.
No DDD logo.
Let her in.
Yeah, we'll just let her in.
Wasn't bad!
Thank you for another 50!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Oh my goodness.
You guys have gotten insane with the...
With the members.
Donos, everything.
This lady, she looks different.
Ah!
Her mouth is down.
I wanna ask.
What's wrong with my appearance?
She looks different.
Look carefully at the photos of my papers and compare them well with them.
I don't remember where she lived.
Oh wait, you also didn't give me your entry request.
Oh.
Here's my entry request.
Thank you.
304.
Yeah, see even the... it's supposed to be way up.
It's supposed to be way, way up.
Lady!
Have a nice day!
This is an easy job.
Mr. Afton.
Hello.
71.
DDD.
Pharmacist.
Wait, where did you live again?
Oh, 301.
Physicist!
Wait.
Oh, physicist.
I think I'm... I think I'm regressing.
You know, it took a lot of energy going from heaven back to manifesting as a ghost.
But you know, maybe I'm losing so much ghostly energy that I'm reverting back into like a...
like a wisp.
Thanks for singing for me.
I was too shy to ask myself and your fans are absolutely evil in the nicest way possible.
Of course, Chris!
If that's really you.
Free supas now!
First name is Dr. W.
Absolutely.
Dr. W.
Afton.
Alright.
250 489 656 489 656 214 214 And I'm pretty sure he was on the list.
So him being out would make sense.
I think we've called even.
1425.
1 4 2 5
Nope.
I think we're good to...
to deny.
3 3 1 2 That's the call You are never coming back home Those don't rhyme but that's okay.
I won't survive the end of the day.
3 3 1 2 Oh!
You again?
My gosh, your place is going to be so crowded, madam reptilian.
Your appearance.
What's wrong with my appearance?
I'm just saying.
Yeah, I did.
I already answered their question.
3 times.
Okay.
Works for me then.
She's so popular.
She's the beauty standard.
Okay.
Moment of truth.
F F F F F F F F F Oh!
10 people killed.
Yeah!
Yippee!
Oh not just I was like scar.
Alright!
Let's go!
7 is crazy.
I know.
We killed 10 people.
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice.
That should also give us another record too though, right?
If we go back to the menu.
Yeah!
Kill an innocent neighbor!
Get the F!
Let's go baby!
I still want to get peach!
And whatever this catch a doppelganger red-handed.
How...
How do you do that?
Scar is an interesting way to say entire face stitched shut.
Right?
You ask questions.
Oh by questioning them!
Oh okay, okay, okay.
Let's try a few more.
Maybe we'll get peaches or maybe... These are kind of longer games so...
I don't mind that...
Uh...
I kind of like that they don't... It doesn't necessarily need a story.
It's just kind of like... You play.
Alright.
Nice.
Now we're playing again for real.
Wait, there was also the... What was it?
The one where you don't touch any folders?
So basically I can't touch any of these, right?
And I have to...
Right?
It said no folders.
So...
I'm assuming I can look at this.
Steal memory...
Uh oh.
What was his phone number?
Wait...
Oh, Mr. Afton!
What was your phone number?
I'm a resident of the building.
I'm not on today's list because I had to leave due to an emergency at work.
3312, you're not gonna get me this time.
1971...
No logo!
No logo, no logo!
No logo, no entry, mister!
No logo, no entry!
Hmm...
Nice.
This is like...
evil Animal Crossing speak.
Like anti-Animal Crossing.
Anti- cute.
Oh...
Oh no.
Promo.
What happened to you?
I don't mean to... I mean...
It's a little... I look like I always do.
It's a little rude to say like, hey, what's wrong with your face?
But, you know, it's just kind of like...
It's just a little...
You know...
Poor guy went to the doctors today and we're sending him to jail.
He's just like, please.
I don't feel so well.
I just want to go home and relax.
Thank you.
He wasn't even on the list.
Hello, Peachman.
Good afternoon.
Shoemaker.
Yes.
Is he on the list?
He is.
He is on the list.
We can't confirm his uh...
his ID number.
But...
You okay, man?
Yeah, I'm okay.
I'm all good.
I think we're just gonna have to...
I think we're just gonna...
Nose looks like it...
Wait.
Oh, no.
His appearance.
Nope.
Everything seems...
according...
to...
as it should be.
Thank you for the raid.
Hello.
I believe this is correct.
I think so.
I think we're good.
Doing our best.
Let's see what's here without the folders.
Okay.
Hello.
Good afternoon.
Arnold.
We remember that he is always wearing a hat.
1971.
Got the logo.
Murphy!
Thanks for the 10 gifted!
All according to Japanese word for plan.
Keikaku means plan.
Oh, was he a writer?
Or did he work at the bank?
I work at the bank.
No.
Who was the accountant?
Roman is the accountant.
And I think Arnold's wife is the banker.
He is a writer.
Getter.
Thanks for the 5 gifted.
Ducky.
Thank you.
Okay, I think we're just gonna have to let this guy in then.
He's on the list too, right?
Yup.
201.
So everything is in order?
I hate people that work at the bank.
I work at the bank.
Thanks for the 5 gifted.
Thank you for the 50.
Fun Comics.
Thank you for the 5.
Please.
Sean.
Thank you for the 10.
Thank you for the 20.
Okay, let's just let him in.
Do you have to get a perfect run to get the achievement?
You do, yeah.
Hello.
Oh gosh, we haven't seen this lady.
Like we've only seen her like one time.
But we can compare her appearance with this.
Looks good.
Looking good.
Lois.
Thank you for the 10.
Kayvar.
Thanks for the 5.
Nick Mack.
Thanks for the 10.
Guys.
Lois Stinky.
1969.
I'm a resident of this building.
I went out to visit my mother.
We got the...
the DDD logos.
Mia.
Thanks for the 5.
Stinky.
I think she's good.
From what we can tell.
I think she's okay.
That's all we can try.
Patkun.
Thanks for the 10.
Beep.
Oh.
Hello.
Margaret.
Miss Bubbles.
Shin.
Thanks for the 10.
Kenja.
Thanks for the 5.
Let's see.
DDD.
1975.
We haven't got...
We've had the expiration date missing.
But we have not had it incorrect.
DDD.
Seamstress.
Is she a seamstress?
I don't know.
I don't...
I don't remember.
If she was a seamstress or not.
Also, let's check her nose.
Her nose is good.
Her face is good.
Eyebrows good.
DDD.
Beep.
Seamstress.
That is actually so true.
Seamstresses.
You are not on the list.
Oh gosh.
Uh oh.
DDD.
I had to leave due to an emergency.
Why is it glitching out?
I think it is correct though.
Her eye color.
I can't remember her nose at all though.
I can't remember her nose.
Oh nose.
I came from my job as a chef.
What kind of chef emergency was there?
I can't remember.
I keep thinking the flying dust in the game is my dirty screen.
DDD.
Wrong nose it is.
We don't have a reference over here.
We also can't call because probably her daughter is out.
Kiyoma, thanks for the 10.
Ellie, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
I don't think the nose is wrong.
DDD.
She should be in though if you call.
Oh true, true, true, true.
No, she was a chef.
She was a chef for sure.
It's Emma Stone that's a teacher.
Does anybody remember the phone number?
Question her more.
Oh.
My ID?
I don't see anything wrong with my ID.
Okay.
Appeared.
What's wrong with my appearance?
She seems so happy about me like really interrogating her.
Did I enter your request?
I don't see anything wrong with my entry.
Why does she say the same thing every time?
Nanoplasm, thank you.
I was just wondering if you got your moguls minted.
Moguls minted?
I don't remember the rest.
I think she's good.
I think, hopefully.
I should probably have changed it so that if you get it wrong, it kills you immediately.
So we don't have to suffer through the entire thing.
Oh!
Hi or whatever.
Give me your ID.
I forgot to show my ID.
Whatever.
Anastacia.
Okay, we got the DDD.
1995.
I live here whatever.
I come from school.
We do know that she is a student.
Whatever.
204.
Anastacia.
Mikael.
She's so good.
She looks...
She looks good.
Every little single hair is in place.
Oh my gosh.
Imagine you had to actually style your hair the same way every day.
You had to literally put the same little strand of hair.
You know?
Yeah.
I think I'm gonna let her in.
Every single tiny strand of her hair.
Hopefully.
Hair stranding.
Oh, hello.
Good afternoon, Angus.
Okay.
He's a businessman.
We didn't know that about you.
I'm nervous because I feel like we're not catching a lot of things.
You know?
I feel like we're...
I don't know.
I look like I'm picking his teeth.
Um...
I don't know.
Oh...
A businessman with a business plan.
Chris is doppelganger?
Hello.
Um...
Wait.
How do I know you're a doppelganger?
Anyone can say that they're the doppelganger.
But...
How will I know?
Prove yourself wrong.
Three, three, one, two.
I think we just gotta put this guy in.
Next.
Good afternoon, old man.
Wait, I don't know you at all.
Uh-oh.
Wait, I don't...
Oh no, it's Alf!
We've never met Alf before.
Uh-oh.
Maybe it's too hard to do the steel difficulty.
No, Alf!
Am I not on today's list?
You are not!
I think there's an error.
I should be on the list.
Look at the list again.
Are you saying that I made a mistake, mister?
No date?
You guys are so good.
You guys are so good!
Nice.
Get out of here, Alfie boy!
Yes.
Squeaky clean.
As if he were never here.
Not even a single debris of flesh left.
Hello.
Where's your ID?
Here's my ID.
Miss Illinois.
Okay, we got the date.
The DDD.
Let's make sure the name is spelled correctly.
Search...
Yep.
Job is a model.
Resident of the building.
I think so.
Goodbye, Monopoly man.
Does the Monopoly man not have a monocle?
Isn't that like one of those Mandela effect things?
She's got the mole on the right side.
She's looking good.
He never did.
Yeah, he never had a monocle.
But a lot of people think he had one.
Thanks, K-Barn!
Silly chat.
Supas aren't free.
Streamlabs, though, are totally free.
Stop!
I think she's good.
It's hard when, uh...
When you can't call to confirm that the person's there or not.
Oh!
Milkman.
Did you stretch them to hear better?
Leah!
Oh my gosh!
Thank you!
Welcome to membership!
Stop!
Thank you so much.
Bunny fursona bag.
Wanna nibble on those.
When people say they like big ears, this is what they mean.
Pointy ears are a thing of the past.
It's all about the lobes now.
We're here for long lobes.
Long lobes.
Yeah!
All that cartilage, baby!
Sorry.
Last time I was able to let you in, but this time I must reject you, Mr. Lobes.
I prefer pointy ears.
No, no.
Don't you see him?
And don't you feel a little excited?
There's something in you that stirs.
Something you didn't recognize before.
Something you were like, hmm.
This is new.
This is different, but I don't hate it.
I think, in fact, I like it.
Good afternoon!
Steven?
Red Boys?
1966?
A pilot.
Wait.
Date.
DDD.
Steven Red Boys.
Go on in, goose.
I heard supers were free, so here's mine.
You have heard incorrectly, Rayson.
But thank you.
Who?
What is the meaning of life, the universe, and everything else?
Oh!
42!
That's correct!
What is the scientific name of the Australian animal that drastically changes its appearance when removed from its natural habitat?
This is the quiz!
Oh my gosh, we got the quiz!
Huh?
Chameleon?
That's what I thought.
Is a chameleon Australian?
The drop bear.
Octopus?
Oh my gosh, the audio is getting kind of freaky.
Scientific name.
Uh.
Made mint.
Quick to Google!
Okay, Google, Google, Google, Google.
Scientific?
Sci-en-tif-ic.
Name.
Of the Australian...
Oh my gosh.
The Australian animal that drastically changes its appearance when removed from its habitat is the echidna!
Scientifically known as the...
It's the echidna?
Sonic Hedgehog?
Ta-ta-chi...
Ta...
Ta-chi...
Glossis...
A-cu-li-a-tis.
No!
But this was an expert verified answer from Google!
It says in the top.
No way!
Aw, man.
I think it was the blobfish.
Why not just echidna?
Because it said the scientific name.
Aw...
Well, we tried the quiz.
We got the quiz.
So that's cool.
We at least got that part.
I'm glad.
No, you're not on the list.
Celine.
Celine, you're not on the list.
Uh...
Wait a second.
Oh, never mind.
Oh, yeah.
It's Ele...
Okay, yeah.
I think we gotta not let her in.
I think we need to not let her in.
1980.
The mole.
No, no, no.
They're twins.
They're two different people.
You have Celine and the other...
They're twins.
The nose.
The nose!
You're so right.
What's wrong with my appearance?
I mean...
I think everything is...
Everything is fine with my appearance.
Hey, I'm Mint in chat.
What's your favorite ice cream flavor?
Mine is chocolate chip mint ice cream.
Have a fantastic weekend.
Chocolate chip mint ice, ice, ice.
My favorite...
I think I really like...
It depends on if I'm in a fruity mood or a milky mood.
I really like Oreo ice cream.
Oreo is so good.
But I also like mint.
Chocolate mint.
Yeah.
It's so funny because a lot of people draw me as like ice cream.
But...
That was never really my intention.
Because especially with like my...
You know, original look.
I was never so...
You know, my name is Mint.
And I wear a lot of mint.
But I was never mint chocolate.
And then...
With this outfit, I only added a little bit of chocolate motifs.
But...
A lot of people draw me as ice cream.
Haha.
What did she say?
Oh, sorry.
I was not paying attention.
What did you say, lady?
I didn't...
What?
You said check it again?
Whatever.
I think we should not let her in.
Because...
Mia Stone...
You did not put your thing about being a teacher.
Oh, emergency at work.
Oh...
No stamp here!
It's so confusing because they put the stamps here.
So like...
I instinctually think that the stamps are going to be there.
You know what I mean?
3...
3... 1...
2...
Mint Oreo ice cream is next level TBH.
Haha.
Skip.
They draw you as ice cream because you are so cool?
Haha.
Thanks.
Hey, Mint.
Chris' wife here.
Have you seen him?
He is running away.
No, I didn't let the doppelganger in.
What?
No!
Who was it?
Just one.
You guys did say the nose.
You guys did say Nacha's nose.
You did say...
That was so close.
Nacha, Nacha neighbor, for real.
You got an A.
Dang.
It was the nose.
I should have known.
Nosed.
Because you guys are experts.
You guys are nose experts.
Apparently.
I really want to see Peaches.
So let's try one more time.
Let's try one more time.
And we are going to also try...
The memory thing as well.
Last run.
LG, LG, LG.
Hello.
Oh my gosh.
It's a full roster.
And maybe we'll get the quiz guy again too.
I came from my job as a model.
And the logo, and the logo, and the date.
Yes, yes, yes.
I think...
That we're good.
She's also on the list.
104, 104, yup.
The thing was the blobfish.
I know.
Everybody's been saying that.
Oh, hello.
Good afternoon.
McCluey Red Boys.
He's always wearing his hat.
It said that.
The thing.
We got a date.
We got a stamp.
Got some numbers.
Can't tell if they're right or wrong.
We have no idea.
His nose seems right.
His mustache seems right.
Everything seems correct.
Doing some shopping.
Oh, he's retired.
So that makes sense.
Um...
He's got the stamp.
Ask to remove his hat.
Can I do that?
Remove your hat, sir.
Blah, blah, blah.
Okay.
I think he's good.
McCluey.
Yeah, that's his name.
Hello, milk.
Meh.
Your nose.
That is not your nose.
That is not the correct nose.
No.
No, no, no, no.
That is not your nose.
That is not his nose.
I know.
It was not his nose.
His nose was not so defined.
I'm almost positive.
I'm like...
Check his file.
No, we're doing a run where we don't check the files.
That was not his nose.
I know it.
Um...
Hello?
Uh...
Entry request?
Not on the list.
Due to an emergency?
What kind of emergency?
Slain?
Uh...
Model.
But no, you said emergency.
The mole?
No, no, that's the sister.
It's the sister.
Yeah,
there's the sister Celine and the sister Ellen...
something.
Ellen...
Illinois.
Illinois, yeah.
Okay, nice.
Good job, everybody.
Oh!
Hello.
Uh, your ID, sir?
Oh, he got back from his lobotomy.
That must be it.
XLR8?
Uh...
You're not...
Oh, sir, you're not on today's list.
Am I not on today's list?
There must be a mistake.
I should be on the list.
Look at the list again.
Lobotomy.
My forehead?
Yeah.
It's nothing.
Just ignore it.
Okay.
Yeah.
Door bar.
I got that Suguru hair like...
Stop.
Learn a thing and talk to me.
Satoru.
When I was gone.
Wait, no.
Gojo.
Satoru.
Hello.
You are always out.
Mr. Angus.
Oh.
ID, please.
Don't make me sob.
1968.
Nose.
Mustache.
Appearance seems...
Typical.
Stamp.
Angus Kipriani.
I think we're good.
I think he's good.
The tie?
No, it's good.
No job?
I don't think they have to say it every time, do they?
I don't think they say it...
They have to say it every time.
I think we're good.
Bye bye.
Next, please.
Uh oh.
Ahh...
The apartment?
Oh my gosh, that's so sneaky.
Wait, no.
It's correct.
Wait.
Oh, 30!
Wow, that's really sneaky!
That is so sneaky!
Sorry, numbers really confuse me.
You almost got got, girl!
I know!
Well, I would have reported him anyway because we already let the other guy in.
I would have sent him away anyway.
Thank you!
Next!
Get over here!
Good afternoon.
Where's your ID?
Yeah, you did forget to show me your ID.
Big mistake, Mia Stone.
Big mistake.
Okay, we got a date.
We've got a We've got a stamp.
We've got some names.
Now I have to worry about other things that I didn't even think about having to check before.
She's a teacher.
Yes, she is.
We got a stamp.
0301.
I think...
I think she's good.
Wait, we didn't let her in earlier, did we?
I don't think we did.
I don't think we let her in earlier.
I think we'll...
I think we're good.
No?
Everything is...
I can't tell if it's my internet or why everything is starting to stutter a little bit.
Alright, let's let her in.
Previous run.
The runs are really fusing together.
They are!
They are.
Hello!
ID!
Yeah, this is...
It's like starting to lag a little bit.
Okay.
Gloria.
This is our last run, so...
Oh my gosh, I thought that was a mole?
I was like...
The mole is on the wrong side!
No seems up to par.
Yes.
Date.
Stamp.
0201 0201 I think we have to let her in.
I think we have to let her in.
I thought so too.
I know, right?
Next!
Next, next, next!
Oh!
Oh my gosh!
Why didn't you guys come in together?
Arnold!
Date.
Let's check your appearance.
You got your handle bar mustache.
Very good.
You got your little hat on.
Job as a writer.
Yes, that's correct as well.
I'm gonna have to let you in.
Hopefully I didn't oversee anything.
Hopefully I didn't miss something.
Hello!
I think we were right though.
Why are you not on today's list?
There must be a mistake.
I should be on the list.
I don't think so.
I don't see you.
We've got a date.
We've got a stamp.
No stamp here.
No go madam.
Security!
Get this!
She is disturbing me!
Please!
I feel unsafe!
Thank you.
Busting!
Next!
No mole.
Oh my god it's the hidden sister.
It's her!
Solidus!
What's wrong with my appearance?
I think everything is fine with my appearance.
Think again.
Do you even think?
Here's my entry request.
Wow she forged it really well.
She's got the stamp and everything.
Yep.
No moles.
No go.
Okay miss.
Miss Illinois.
Little do we know.
She's coming back from the doctors.
She's just like.
I just had the worst day.
Getting this mole removed was so much more painful.
Than I imagined it to be.
I forgot to tell the entrance.
They'll recognize me.
They'll let me in.
It's no big deal.
And we send her.
To jail.
Or to die.
I don't know.
Do they die or they...
Good afternoon.
Where is your entry request?
Thank you.
Mia...
Didn't we let Mia Stone in before already?
Uh oh this one.
Wait.
Yes we did.
The second wife.
The second.
1978.
I hope it wasn't like.
The numbers were wrong.
Like the ID numbers.
Because there's no way.
I'm a resident of the building.
I come from my job as a teacher.
Anyone could know that.
Anyone could know Mia Stone's a teacher.
You creepy doppelganger.
Hmm.
Guess we'll just have to not let her in.
I think.
I think we'll just have to not let her in.
The last one had no logo?
No logo?
If that was the last one, I'm going to cry.
You bitch!
Get out of here!
Get out of here with your round face!
I don't want to see you!
No!
I can't believe we messed up!
I should have... I should have kept track.
I should have kept track of whether I...
Old man!
Please...
I don't even feel like... I don't even feel the motivation anymore.
Ugh.
Rip run.
Yeah.
He seems fine.
Doesn't matter anyway.
Just let him in.
How many people are left?
No!
You always have your hat on!
Roman!
Wait.
I want to ask him about it.
Oh my appearance.
Is it because of my hat?
I forgot it at home.
He didn't call my apartment and ask my wife.
Wait.
I didn't expect that answer.
I thought he said he'd like lose it or something.
No way.
You left it at home?
That sounds like a reasonable answer.
This can happen?
He doesn't have a wife.
Oh yes he does.
And this is a lucky man.
Have you seen his wife?
Good golly.
She's got...
And she also has...
And a ton of...
1-1-5-2.
Thank you guys.
Lois Stiltski speaking.
My husband is not at home.
Did he forget his hat?
His hat?
Yes, yes, yes.
Yes he left it here!
I almost... I almost sent you to die Roman.
I almost sent you to die.
Have a good day.
How many are left?
Peach man.
You me of stone.
I'm never watching La La Land again.
I'm a La La Land auntie now.
Oops.
Everything about the appearance seems fine.
I don't know why I'm still carrying.
Maybe I'm hoping for a miracle.
Something.
Go in.
Oh.
No date.
Bum
bum bum.
He fell down the stairs.
He left something in his car obviously.
He had to run out really fast.
Go grab it.
Bum bum bum.
Wait.
So I also let a guy in?
Neighbors killed one.
Wait.
Who did I let in then?
Mia.
Fake documents.
Oh god the game is like starting to lag so bad.
I think we let in fake Mia.
Annoying!
So frustrating!
It's harder.
It's of course harder when you can't see the records.
But I mean honestly we did pretty good job for...
I think we just mixed up the Mias.
But we did a pretty good job for not having the records to be able to reference too.
I think we killed the correct Mia.
And we accidentally let in the bad Mia.
I think.
Haha.
Thank you guys for... Catching some... Some ghastly ghouls with me today.
Let's see, what achievements do we have left still?
There's no A?
There's only S and F?
Oh yeah, Chester's quiz.
40 playthroughs.
Which we did not survive the past couple ones.
That's okay.
Doppelganger red-handed.
Yeah, it's this one.
Survive without opening any folder.
Wait!
All we have to do is survive, right?
So we kill all of them.
Doesn't that technically mean...
We'll survive?
I should have chosen a different username every time you said this stream.
I got jumped in.
Sorry.
That works?
It does?
We die if a doppel gets in.
Yeah, but if we just...
Don't let anybody in, then it should be fine.
Right?
You know what?
One more!
Let's try it.
Let's cheat the system.
This one should be fast because we're just killing everybody.
Blood!
Yes!
Death to you!
Oh wait!
If we can catch a guy red-handed...
That would also be another thing, right?
No, you seem safe though.
No survivors!
Kill!
Next!
Victim.
Yeah.
Milkman.
Hello.
Francis.
You are on the list.
See?
That's his nose.
That's his nose, you guys.
The other nose had too much definition.
There was like little holes and stuff for him to breathe.
But he doesn't have those to breathe.
He's a mouth breather.
No logo?
It doesn't matter.
We're not gonna let him in anyway.
We're not letting in a single person.
Is this the...
Is this the milkman that Tumblr is going wild for?
What do you mean by that?
Is Tumblr still a thing?
Good afternoon.
Blah blah blah.
Doesn't this guy normally wear a hat anyway?
Is it because of my hat?
Yes!
Actually.
Oh.
I'm not gonna do that.
It's okay.
He lived a long life.
People are simping for the milkman.
No way.
Wait, actually?
Oh.
Her eye is going the wrong way.
She's also not on the list.
What's wrong with my appearance?
Look carefully at the photos of my papers and compare them well with me.
No, I want you to get hangry.
Get mad!
Okay.
You're boring.
Get out of here.
What did you say?
Maybe I clicked the button before she finished talking.
It kind of spooked me, though.
It kind of scared me when I shut it and she's like, look at the list again.
A lot of lewd fan art of him on Twitter!
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
Wait.
Is he on the sexy Tumblerman Tumblr website?
Good afternoon.
Good afternoon, Mr. Schmidt.
You have no stamp.
What's up with that?
Oh.
I am ruthless today.
Yes, but it's usually the other eye that is deviated.
Yeah.
No, I already said that.
As soon as she walked up, I recognized that.
I knew that already.
You guys are too slow.
It was her other eye that was opposite.
Why are you guys trying to correct me when I said that?
I'm confused.
Maybe I didn't word myself correctly.
I'm just going to...
Brian Rahm, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
They're correcting other people in chat.
Okay.
Oh, man.
The other eye is offset.
No way!
What?
They're bullshitting.
Anyway.
Skip.
Chat backseated themselves.
It's okay.
I know.
This gets a little confusing.
Oh!
His nose is so wrong, actually.
Yeah, what's wrong with your appearance?
I look as handsome as ever!
You're so right.
I want his confidence.
I want his confidence for real.
He just has a cold.
He got stung by a bee.
I know!
Thank you!
You guys are putting in the work today.
Hello!
What is the meaning of life, universe and everything else?
42!
That is correct.
What is the scientific name of the Australian animal that drastically changes its appearance when removed from its natural habitat?
Why did Google tell me to get kidnapped?
Psi...Psi...Psi...Psi...
Chri...lo...ty...mar...sid...us...
I'm...I'm...I'm...
Psi...chri...lo...ty...mar...sid...us...
That's correct!
Good job guys!
What is the name of the only sport that allows you to punch your opponent in the face because they capture a piece?
Rugby?
Chess boxing?
What?
That's a thing?
That's correct!
At least how many times do you have to fold a 0.01mm thick sheet of paper to cover the distance between the Shire and Mordor?
38?
What?
What does that even mean?
Wait, how many times do you have to fold a 0.01mm thick sheet of paper to cover the distance between the Shire and Mordor?
What does that mean?
You have to fold it 38 times to...huh?
How many pages between mentions of the two, I guess?
Yeah, I don't really understand.
Every fold doubles the thickness.
Yeah, but...
Okay, I think I get it.
It's just not possible though.
That's correct!
Good job Google!
The key is...
Hide...
Wait, what?
Oh, I screenshot it because I thought it would...wait.
What?
Uranus?
What does it mean though?
What does the cipher mean?
I like how you guys are just looking this up and spoon feeding it to me.
Thank you.
We're so smart today, guys.
That's correct!
Who would have thought?
How long is this quiz?
According to FSM Global Warming, it's a consequence of the fact that since the 19th century, the number of blank decrease.
Pirates?
Really?
That's correct!
You managed to answer all my questions correctly!
Congratulations, you have earned my badge!
Thank you!
Oh!
Goodbye!
All right!
MVP!
Except for when it's for me!
Because I googled it.
And it said Echidna.
Why did it say Echidna?
Why?
That does not make any sense!
I thought there was maybe something about the Echidna that I just didn't know.
I don't know.
Unless it was ChatGPT.
Who knows?
Bob Burger's looking ass down!
Um...
I think he's fine.
But we're just gonna call...
You know...
If I touch this thing...
Will I get diseased?
We'll figure...
We'll find out after...
If I touch this little thing he gave me...
That's a certified hot dog moment!
Can I get a hot dog?
Thank you!
Bye-bye!
Nope.
Doesn't...
Nothing happens if you click it.
Milkman!
Hello.
I forgot to show my entry request.
You're a milkman.
Thank you, Francis.
Oh my gosh, thank you for that!
Thank you, cat called Meowie.
Tips are free.
No, they're not!
No, they are not.
Thank you, though.
Um...
I think he was fine.
But who knows?
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for all the hot dogs!
Glizzy.
Overdrive.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
After this, I have to go blow my nose for real.
I had the...
I had my door open today to kind of air out my maid cafe a little bit.
Because, you know, since I haven't been...
Since I haven't been living here...
For a while, it was a little stuffy.
Um...
But it let all the pollen in too.
So I'm like extra...
Extra stuffy and coffee today.
She's Tomie.
They are my arms.
Like the arms of a normal human.
She's so right.
You are so right.
That's fun.
We haven't seen that one before.
Sniffer.
Very natural.
Very human.
Actually, those kind of look like my hands, didn't they?
They kind of look like...
They kind of look like my hands.
When they're up, you know.
Good afternoon.
Do I have to let you think like one person in?
Oh my god, my nose is so itchy!
Maybe she was a ghost too.
Maybe!
Maybe she like...
Maybe she was in the process of becoming a ghost, you know, she was dead and then she got brought back to life.
Imagine giving her a hug and then her neck arm hug your head too.
That's so romantic!
Good afternoon.
Where's your entry request?
Thank you.
McLouie Rudd Boys.
I think he's good, but it's fine.
Romance.
Just like what I think of when I see Italy.
We're gonna cause a time paradox.
Thank you.
Yes, romance.
Exactly.
Yippee!
And we got five doppelgangers.
Nice.
We only killed seven people in the process too, but that's okay.
Rank C!
And we got a new record.
Right?
Which is...
Yeah!
I can't believe that worked.
Wow.
We actually managed to unlock so many of these.
Obviously the hundred one is gonna be really difficult.
Forty playthroughs.
Unlock all achievements.
The peach doppelganger and the doppelganger red hair?
I don't understand it.
Actually, if you are interested in playing this game too, it is free.
There is like a download version that costs three dollars, I think.
So it's very inexpensive.
And then there's also a free browser version.
Dust go!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
So...
Yeah.
You can...
You can play it for free in the online version.
Just search up...
That's not my neighbor.
And you will be able to find it.
If you are interested in playing it as well.
Because it is pretty fun.
Look, we have already captured thirty one doppelgangers.
That's not so bad.
What was the...
How many was it?
Like a hundred?
A hundred!
We are already thirty percent of the way there.
It's not so bad.
Yeah, it's not so bad.
Megafishnet, thank you!
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Welcome back.
And sent thirty...
Shh, we don't look at that part.
We don't look at this one.
In fact, I'm gonna...
Actually, we have only sent one neighbor.
We've only killed one neighbor.
Yeah, no worries.
No worries at all.
Well, that was good.
I'm glad that we could get those last two achievements then, right?
Very good stream.
I hope you're doing well.
Thanks, Robert!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
This is so fun.
Andrew, welcome to the membership.
Thank you!
Thank you for the twenty!
Gifted!
Thank you!
I have to...
I think...
My next day off...
I will search for like...
Artists and stuff for...
My...
For emotes and everything.
See who's open for...
For...
What's the word?
Commissions!
So...
Yeah.
I will look into that.
My name is Jeff.
10 out of 10 stream.
Well, thank you, Jeff.
I'm glad you liked it.
First time ever seeing this game.
It was fun.
I hope you had a good rest of the day.
Thank you, Merlin!
Thank you!
Yeah, I...
I...
Was really...
I saw this like a ton...
On YouTube and TikTok when I was in Japan.
And so I was like...
Trying not to watch so much of it because I obviously wanted to play for myself and I didn't want to be so...
Spoiled.
I'm kind of like...
I don't want to call them anomalies.
What kind of doppelgangers you can get, right?
Thanks for the stream, Mint!
Unless you're not Mint and you're a doppelganger.
Then please give us Mint back.
Here, hold on.
Hold on.
Let's see.
Let's see if you can tell if I'm a doppelganger or not.
Okay?
Let's see.
Hmm...
Oh, wait.
Hold on.
Let's see if you can tell if I'm a doppelganger or not.
Okay.
I'm gonna come in.
You're gonna tell me if I'm a doppelganger.
Hello!
Am I normal?
Sos?
Where?
Why?
Why Sos?
Actually...
Here...
Um...
Let's actually move over to...
Here.
I'm gonna exit out of the game.
So we don't get this creepy music anymore.
Um...
Put on some music.
Some music.
There we go.
Sos?
Double mated?
Then you send me...
Then you call...
You call the police on me and I get flushed down the toilet.
No!
Okay.
Let me try one other one.
Oh!
Let me try another one.
Let's see.
Um...
I...
That one was too easy.
Oh...
This one.
You'll never get it.
You'll never know.
Okay.
Ready?
Unchanged.
This is normal.
That's what I'm saying.
Okay.
Alright?
You don't know.
Okay, I'm gonna give you another one.
But...
You have to tell me.
You have to figure it out.
This one?
Is normal.
Or?
Wait, okay, no.
This one?
Okay, figure out which one is normal.
Or...
This one?
Which one?
Yes, I'm a very dignified gentleman.
It's getting in my eyes.
It's itchy.
Why is it so wiggly?
There we go.
What is this?
What do I make it bigger?
Like this.
This is peak...
This is what every man should strive to be.
Masculinity.
Peak normal.
Robotnik.
This is mine!
Oh, I need an eye patch.
No, a monocle.
There are so many things here that are fun to use.
Let's see what else we got in here.
What?
There's boba in here too.
Hold on, I want to try it.
Woah!
How does this work?
Yummy!
Wait...
I can hold it in my hands.
Right?
Woah!
Wow!
Look at me!
I got my bubble tea!
Wow!
It's so fancy!
Oh my god.
Oh my gosh.
We have the technology.
Wow, this is so cool!
What does it say?
Boba?
Tea?
Coffee?
Oh!
Like BTS!
Vtube Studio!
Oh my gosh, that's so cute!
Vtube Studio is great, right?
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
Yippee!
That's kind of drippy though.
It's getting my sleeves wet.
Can we have a sippy too?
Drink up!
Here, I'll put it in the sand.
I'm feeding you.
Suckle.
Suckle from the straw.
See if you can catch it.
Only the strongest will survive.
Come on!
If you can't get it, you won't live to see another day!
I am trying!
What else is there?
Let's see.
There's also these!
Will these look good on me though?
I wonder.
Okay, I'm gonna try.
Wait.
I'm gonna disappear.
Wait, I'm confused.
Actually.
Wait, hold on.
Why is it just...
I'm confused.
Oh!
There we go.
Okay.
You guys ready?
This one's kind of...
Well, maybe it's just the angle.
What do you think?
This would've been perfect for Easter.
Too bad I...
Too bad we announced everything the day after.
Bonnie.
Bonnie, Bonnie.
Uh...
You probably won't have to worry about this, but it could be an idea how to placeholder...
placeholder emotes while looking for a placeholder.
But I think you'll have plenty of members for months.
Not worry about it.
Oh, that's a good idea.
That's a good point though.
Because yeah.
You're right.
I might lose them.
Thank you!
I like how when I blink, they move.
That's so fancy.
The technology.
The technology is real.
And they also like, flop back and forth.
Yay!
Too cute.
So cute.
Yeah, I'll probably find a couple artists that can do some...
some stuff.
So that...
Uh...
I'm not stressing one artist out with 37...
37 slots.
Um...
Or however many it was.
It was 37, wasn't it?
Or did I just see that in chat and believed it?
37 copies of Bustin'?
Yes.
Dr. Cornelius.
Thank you for membership!
God Hand, thank you for membership!
Ah, God Hand.
37, you counted them yourself.
Okay.
Welcome to membership, thank you!
38?
37 colors of Bustin'.
Oh my gosh, we just make it a full spectrum?
That would be crazy.
It's like a full rainbow spectrum.
Like every individual color.
You can think of 37 stab wounds!
Yeah.
Hmm...
Well guys, this was fun.
Thank you for hanging out with me today.
Thank you for understanding when I was just like...
Part of me for Tomodachi life I was like, obviously I can put in like some...
Some... what's the word?
Like fictional characters.
We can put in like video game characters, anime characters, whoever we want.
But for...
Or even like celebrities.
You know, just be goofy.
But for some of the people that I was just like...
Oh, like you know...
For...
Other people that I might know personally if I wanted to put them in.
I wanted to...
Thank you!
I wanted to make sure I ask for like...
You know, permission.
You know, like I want to be like...
I don't want to just put them in the game and they...
You know.
I was just like...
I thought about it like kind of...
Like really only today.
So I was like, oh shoot.
Not that I have like so many people that I would include.
But just in case anybody that I know that...
I might include.
Yeah.
I just want to make sure that they are okay with it.
Before I add them in.
Like Matara, yeah.
No.
I'm never asking if she's comfortable.
I want her to be as uncomfortable as possible.
All the time.
Okay.
Tomorrow will probably be a bit of a longer stream.
Because...
It's Metal Gear!
Yippee!
Mint the rabbit hole animation.
Hmm?
Rabbit hole?
Yeah, I'll be playing Twin Snakes tomorrow.
For the first time ever.
So I'm nervous.
If I'm bad, I'm sorry.
I haven't played Metal Gear in quite some time.
So...
But uh...
We...
Will...
Have fun regardless.
Oh, the Miko MV!
Do do do.
Yeah yeah yeah.
I know it.
Yes yes yes.
I forgot what it was called.
Big ham.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
But yeah.
So Metal Gear tomorrow.
The hype.
So excited to play it.
Twin Snakes.
Finally.
And um...
Yeah, probably will be a bit of a longer stream so that I can get through a good amount of it.
And I will make sure I... well, hopefully I will get enough sleep tonight.
Hopefully.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I will see you guys tomorrow!
Bye bye!
Oh, we can do Bustin'.
Actually, it's so funny.
Yesterday I watched a trailer of an anime and I got bonked.
So the stream got demonetized.
The stream got demonetized because they were like, you showed the trailer and you also watched it.
So I have to be careful about that kind of stuff, I suppose.
Yeah... it's okay though.
I'm not like... gonna cry about it.
But...
I want to make sure that things aren't so loud so that they don't get caught so easily, you know?
Yeah, the Med Wars one.
Even though I was just like... over top of it, it recognized the video which is so crazy.
Right?
There's something strange...
Sleeping in your bed...
Let me tell you something...
There's something weird...
Sleeping in your bed...
Let me tell you something...
Bustin' makes me feel good...
Bustin' Bustin' Bustin' Bustin' Bustin' Bustin' Bustin' Bustin' Bustin' You paused it a bunch?
Too many times and you still caught it.
I know, right?
I was really surprised.
YouTube's...
It makes me worried about...
About livestreams and stuff like that now.
Like watching the animals and stuff.
At the aquarium.
Bum Bum Da Da Da Da Bum Yeah Yeah Yeah Yeah An invisible man...
Sleeping in your bed.
Oh!
Wah!
Garlabelle thank you!
I don't...
No No really?
It's okay!
OMG, not the picture...
It's going perfectly with the...
With the song!
Feel good...
Bustin' Bustin' Bustin' Bustin' Bustin' Bustin' Makes me feel good!
Feel good, feel good, feel good.
Freaky ghost man.
Freaky man baby.
All alone, let me sleep in your bed.
Let me tell you something.
Sleeping makes me feel good.
I ain't afraid of no sleep.
I ain't afraid of no bed.
An invisible bed.
Freaky ghost man.
Busting, busting makes me feel good.
Feel good, feel good, feel good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Busting, busting, busting, busting, busting.
Busting, busting, busting makes me feel good.
Feel good, feel good, feel good.
Feel good, feel good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Feel good, feel good, feel good.
Good, yeah, yeah, yeah, good,
feel good, Boston makes me feel good, thank you guys, thank you, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye, see you tomorrow, bye-bye.